uh i don't think i i've
probably been to i think i've been to
afghanistan not at least nine
times on every trip
and and in between i've always talked
about
the status of women and girls in
afghanistan
it's important to women and girls it's
important to the whole country
it is indicative of whether they will
have security
fairness and again we do not want to
erase the advances that were made
uh over a period of time for women and
girls and in my travels of course i've
met with women
in kabul and professional women and that
and that's interesting i'm happy to see
their advances but we've also gone out
to the hinterland
lands to see the poorest of the poor
women as well as to schools to see
little girls
now in school and the rest and to just
to see so much of the progress that was
made
to be reversed is something that we have
to
keep a bright light on i i was
privileged to be
part of honoring uh laura bush
for her work for afghan women this has
been completely nonpartisan in fact
if you want to say bipartisan laura bush
michelle obama
democratic women and republican senators
democratic women
democratic republican women in the house
and across the country
uh so in an event i i think that's sort
of a
bellwether of of how things are there
how things will be uh for uh for women
and girls um
nonetheless uh again i salute the
president i've said this to my
colleagues
we could not be better served by men
than by this
president making this decision at this
time
a former vice president a chair of the
foreign affairs committee a person who
every time he speaks
at the end he said god bless our troops
he cares about our troops he cares about
our security he understands strategic
thinking about our mission on how we
protect the american people
and how we prioritize all of that
so i you know i'm very prayerful as i
say
how proud we are of the action that he
had the courage to take
and i thank him all for that and
speaking of courage i just want to say
as i was coming over here
every time i see the capitol police i
want to thank them thanks and thank them
of course
i'm very indebted to my own security
detail for
the security they provide to me i uh
we were very sad this week to have the
service for billy
officer billy evans in the rotunda of
the capitol
where his family came enabled us to pay
tribute to him to thank him
but in thanking him to thank all of the
capitol police
uh for saving our lives on that horrible
day
january 6th uh and and again
uh for being a force to protect our
capital
we'll be moving forward with a secure a
um supplemental i'm just waiting for the
latest
i think we just got as we were leaving
here from the appropriations committee
uh to have the uh prioritizing of how
what we need to do as soon as possible
to harden the capital
to increase the police force and its um
and its train the capital police force
and its training
uh to uh shall we say compensate
other entities that expended resources
on that day and since then again
to to bring it all to justice
uh mr living good mr smith
mr chestnut mr gibbons we never want to
forget
any of them who had the courage to
protect
the capital our temple of democracy
eight questions
yes sir do you expect two questions the
security supplemental this month
and could you give a sense of how you do
expected this month
and could you give a sense of how large
it's gonna be
i'll go back and review it now the the
uh
it's about again expended that day
so there were actual expenditures that
day
and it's about what this architect of
the capital
wants you to harden the windows the
doors and the rest that's a big
ticket item it's how we compensate
uh some of the national
the reserves and the you know in that
how do we go to that place that's how we
expand the police force to fill in the
vacancies that are there or perhaps
expand beyond that
as well as the training so it's about
the physical structure and the human
resources
as we go forward as well as bills that
need to be paid from
january 6. well i you know i'll
take a look and we'll we'll see we want
to bring it as soon as possible
because we want to get going the
architects
others have informed me that it's very
hard to make a decision about do you
have a
a temporary fence or roll out fence
unless you have some idea if you're
going to
how much it's going to cost and you
can't find that out unless uh you take
steps forward so that
that is you know that's been
controversial uh
i don't think anybody wants a fence
around the capitol a permanent chance
around the capital
but we do want to protect the capital
and we want to protect those who protect
the capital because but we do see this
as as soon as we can
uh to have it be again the
as you call it the temple of democracy
that is that people can come and feel
safe
most of the restrictions right now
though
are because of covet and that's not to
be confused about
why we can't have this meeting or that
meeting it's largely because of covet so
the two
so some of the expenses and the bill
will relate to covet as well
but we'll have it soon yes sir thank you
madam speaker do you support
jerry gatler's bill to expand the
supreme court by forces
and would you commit to bringing that
bill to the floor no
i i support the president's commission
to study
such a proposal but um frankly
i'm not right now our
we're back our members our committees
are working we're building the infras
putting together the infrastructure bill
and the rest i don't know if that's a
good idea or a bad idea
i think it's an idea that should be
considered and i think the president's
taking the right approach
uh to um to have a commission to study
such a thing it's a big step
it's not out of the question it has been
done before
in the history of our country a long
time ago and the growth of our country
the size of our country the growth of
our challenges in terms of
the economy etc might necessitate such
a thing uh but uh it answers your
question i have no plans to bring it to
the floor
given the um potential flexibility the
senate parliamentarian has offered the
other chamber on
more reconciliation bills did you give
us any insight into your thinking about
how you'll approach the jobs plan in
terms of do you think you might do
multiple bills single development
have any of those decisions been made
yet and kind of how are you looking at
that
well uh i don't right now we're awaiting
any
uh guidance from the senate as to
what that actually means uh as i've said
to you before
i don't get involved in their rules and
they don't get involved in our group
however for us to proceed uh
we just need to know what are how we
meet the needs of the american people
what our goals are what the needs are
and how we
prioritize that spending how
it will fit i hope it wouldn't need a
reconciliation bill
but we'll be ready if it does
given that also you've got smaller
majority to work with now too does it
make it easier for you to split
this package up into more pieces or are
you agnostic on that
i'm not in frankly the process
will the the policy will determine the
process
the process will not determine the
policy so when we go forward
with what the president has put forward
uh as
a guidance not a bill it's uh it's a
recommend uh
24 pages or whatever of uh
priorities uh we'll we'll work with the
senate
walk across the aisle hopefully work
across the capitol
walk work down pennsylvania avenue uh
and uh i don't want to spend a whole lot
of time
on is it one bill is it two bills it is
the legislation that will need
as we proceed but what the conversation
not to take away from the conversation
is about
these are priorities of of importance to
the american people
air their children breathe the the job
opportunities in
building the infrastructure but not only
building it the commerce that will flow
from it the broadband that we are
desperate need of either
in rural america yes but in urban
deserts
as well so that's where our conversation
is
how we process it
we'll see it's not important madam
speaker um
a number of uh lawmakers on the
republican side have been going to the
border have been going to
a lot of his border facilities and have
been calling on you as well as president
body and vice president harris to make
these same trips
what's your response to that right
schedule is not determined by the
republicans in the congress of the
united states
it never has been uh nor are is their
schedule determined by me
i've been to the border many times i've
been to the northern triangle
right up until close to the time of the
uh
covert descending upon us but i'm glad
you brought up the border because i do
think uh that uh and i
i commend my colleagues as well as the
president
for being solution oriented there the
fact
is that the trump administration made a
mess because they did not share the
values of any respect for any
people there i've talked about the three
r's
go to the root cause go to the northern
triangle as the vice president is going
to do
go to the root cause see what is there
when i was there with a delegation what
we saw
of course confirmed what we knew
we suspected about violence about
corruption
what i didn't suspect until i got there
was the
impact of the climate crisis
on production of food and agriculture
and occupations related to that
that were a source of migration to our
country
many of these people are coming here
because they are hungry
because they are hungry and so we have
to
help there it didn't help that the
administration the previous
administration
cut off the resources that were there
for the
that region to meet the needs of people
so that they could stay
home this is our hemisphere
since we're neighbors let's be friends
mr rogers
and we could have done for them to cut
off those resources
i think uh mr i we had a a uh
codel there one to cut it off but
in any event that that is now usaid
has resumed an um initiative to be
helpful there
so that people stay home
uh that's root causes the second
are reconstruct
how we deal with this at the border
again
the trump people had it wrong and it has
to be
in order to reconstruct you have to
deconstruct you have to take down
some of the things that they have done
and that means that we want to
facilitate accommodating whether it's
children coming in so that they are not
in the hands of the the uh
as well intentioned as the board of
control is that's not what they're
equipped to do
they can move quickly to oor which is
the health and human services
uh auspices under which those children
will come forth and most people are
being sent back
most people are being sent back but
you've got to you have to have a plan
and you have to have it uh one that it
will work
and and that's what is in the process
and then the third part
root causes reconstruct
the third is refugees we have a moral
responsibility
in the world as every other country does
too
to receive refugees who have a
well-founded fear persecution or harm
to return to their own country uh as
i've told you before and i'll tell you
again
uh when we had uh a hearing
uh uh one what the former president um
did the muslim ban four years ago
like a month ago we had a hearing we
were not the majority it had to be an
informal hearing
and the people who came to that hearing
where our national security people
advised military people came and said
you
have to respect refugees we make
promises
to people in other countries that if we
help them
that they we will help keep them safe so
they don't pay a price
for helping us that's going to be useful
in terms of
afghanistan in fact but in terms of the
border so
secondly the diplomats as you may recall
a thousand diplomats signed a letter
objecting to what the president had done
because it would affect so many refugees
and
this is my closer the
uh american association of
evangelicals they spoke out
about refugees and they said america's
united states resettlement program of
refugees
is the crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
so we have to recognize our moral
responsibility as we
see other countries take in refugees and
the rest i think right now we have
well it's a very few thousand and we
have to increase that number
but again with a well-founded
purpose a well-founded fear not to be
abused
but to be valued so again
i think that people should feel
confident that there is a path
if you attack the root causes if you
reconstruct how you deal with it
and you have a value system uh to
respect with our moral responsibility
as a country
at this time defense russ thank you mr
blackwell is a statehead rebuttal
yes you're not you may proceed
uh a type commission uh i as
many of you heard me say before was the
author of the commission
it at 9 11. i won in committee i lost on
the floor it wasn't until
tim romer our colleague brought it up
again with the help
of the families of 9 11 that it passed
uh the congress and next uh that was
established
the challenge that we have is what is
the scope
the scope what we want is one thing the
truth
what happened on 9 11 how we can prevent
it from happening again
it's not about reviewing the elections
it's not about examining
black lives matter it's about what
happened
on january 6th and how we can prevent it
from happening again so if we can agree
on scope
i think that we can agree on a
commission the
size timing all the rest of that those
are negotiable and that
that that's not the main part of it
that's what they like to say
to hide from the fact that there that
scope is
a part of the difference that we have
had
but i'm optimistic because but quite
frankly we have to have a commission in
my view
we have to find the truth and um
and whatever compromise we have to make
to
to get to that place uh as uh
as you weigh the equities uh
the truth must prevail so now but
again if they can't we can't come to
that
or even if we do we still may want a
select committee
uh to review it because when we did 9 11
you wouldn't recall you were all too
young but at that time we also
had a joint committee house
and senate i was a co-chair of it it was
bob
senator bob graham and senator spector
in the senate
porter goss we were split i mean the
democrats had the senate the republicans
had the house so so um bob graham was
the chair
in the senate intelligence committee
port august was the chair in the house
but we were four co-chairs
of that committee and we did extensive
work that was useful
useful to the uh selected to the
commission when it took place a at when
it
was formed a and b uh the committees
will always continue to do their work
in terms of their responsibilities
whether it's the security of this
building or whether it is the um
the fact of domestic terrorists
in our country who are threat to this
building this democracy and that
particular day which was a day to
ascertain who would be
the president of the united states thank
you all very much
should sign the presidential
determination on refugees
so